- It's a marionette.
- Where's, I mean y'all are
enough but where's Jack?
- [Keegan] Where's Jack?
- Where is Jack?
- [Charlie] Uhhhh.
- Where di he go, why isn't he here?
- I don't know he was, I.
- He was, he was here.
- He was definitely with us,
he was definitely with us and
I don't know where he is now
but he was, he was right
behind us wasn't he?
- [Kelly] Is he still in the building?
- No he's definitely in the building,
he has to be in the building.
- I just saw him.
- [Kelly] Okay
[Chris] I thought I saw him.
- He was 100% with us.
- [Kelly] Should I go check on him or ?
- [Charlie] Yes, might wanna find him.
- [Chris] Yeah.
- Yes please Kel because he
was right, he was with us.
He was with us.
- All right I'll just go get him I mean he
want a special entrance I guess.
I don't know what's happening.
Jack.
Oh.
(laughter)
- Hey Kelly.
- You
(laughter)
You look awesome.
- Thank you.
- You, well what's wrong buddy.
- I'm not going out there.
- [Kelly] Why?
- 'cause everybody said
we were gonna get dressed in costumes
and I'm the only stupid guy
that got dressed in a costume.
And I'm not going out there now.
- [Kelly] No they're
stupid, you look awesome.
I love Bowser.
I love Bowser. Hey you know what,
I got a special entrance,
you wanna go VIP?
They got like the regular ones.
- Yeah, all right.
- Yeah.
- If you got a special entrance.
- It's a special
entrance, Bowser entrance.
All right, everybody Jack Black!
(applause)
Here we go, here we go
(intimidating music)
(applause)
- Whoa!
- That was a really high kick.
- Wow.
- A very high kick.
- You're limber Bowser.
- I'm sorry what, what happened.
- I thought you look great, why did,
I thought, were you all gonna dress up?
Like what happened?
- I think it was like a really funny trick
they played on me.
Like, we're all gonna
get dressed in character,
and then they didn't and
I can't get it off now.
It's like, someone put superglue in there.
- I think you look awesome.
- Thank you Kelly.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(applause)
- I'm not even talking to you guys.
I am so mad at you.
- Okay I'm sorry.
- You really did kind of let
him down. But you look amazing.
Um wait, okay, so you're obviously Bowser
which by the way is my six
year old boy's favorite.
He dresses like Bowser
in my house, no joke.
I don't know what that
is, cause its a villain
and when you're six year
old is rooting for him
it's a little weird, but.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, that's scary foreshadowing,
but who does everyone
else play in the movie?
Obviously Mario.
- Mario for me, yep.
- Luigi.
- I'm Luigi.
- I play Toad.
- Yes!
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I love, I'm so
(applause)
I'm like a kid of the eighties right,
so I grew up playing this game.
I still play this game, it's literally,
my Switch is in my bag,
like I love playing.
- [Keegan] That's awesome.
- I'm a nerd.
Um, so I'm very excited about it.
Can you tell us about the movie like,
what is it gonna be like?
- Well.
- Saving the princess.
- It's
(laughter)
- Right.
- The studio is Illumination,
so if you know Despicable
Me, you know, The Minions.
Illumination they're, they've
got a great track record
so they teamed up with
the folks at Nintendo.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And created The Super
Mario Brothers movie
and it's you know, a narrative,
90 minute epic adventure.
It's, the music is incredible.
It's full of like nostalgia,
but also it's done in a very beautiful
and contemporary cutting
edge way with animation.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's so funny, these guys
are absolutely incredible, um.
- The trailer is hilarious and cool.
- [Keegan] Yeah, it's super cool.
- How it comes to life. Yeah.
- I mean you know when people say
it's the movie version of the game,
it is the movie version of the game.
It is high octane, it's the,
the excitement level is at like a 12.
It's really really terrific. Yeah.
- I love that.
(applause)
I'm so stoked.
- You're gonna love it.
- So wait, I have to ask though, I saw,
I saw this picture online
and I'm just wondering
if you were just going
for the Tom Selleck thing
or this was for Mario,
like what's happening
here in this picture.
- [Chris] Ha ha. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Is this?
- [Chris] That's, that's
new year's I had a,
I grew out my mustache for
something that I was doing and uh
- Oh okay.
- And that was, yeah.
But it wasn't, I like to say
I grew it out to do the voice.
- [Kelly] You were very method.
- Yeah it was that.
- Very method.
- [Chris] Deep into the character.
- Like what would it feel like?
- When you're in the, well
you know you guys do music.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know how the mustache sounds and uh.
- Does that make it rock more Jack?
- I'm not talking to you guys.
(laughter)
But I thought it looked a little more
like a Three Musketeer.
- I was going Dark Tanya all day long.
- [Jack] Mario doesn't have
the soul patch downstairs,
you know?
- Yeah, you were working
almost a full Van Dyke there.
Swack.
- [Kelly] Actually all of
y'all in a musketeer movie
would be amazing.
- That would be good.
- Oh with the Three Musketeers, four
- Yeah I was like this would be amazing.
(laughter)
- So wait, did y'all
test out different voices
for the characters, because I,
even I heard you in the
thing go "Lets a go!"
Like how, 'cause I'm a
nerd and I love Mario,
but like did y'all like
test out different voices
for your characters, like?
- I have a very hard time
not sounding like a
cartoon character, so yeah.
(laughter)
- It's like, it's just innate?
- Yeah, it's just uh, it
just comes out weird. Yeah.
- Oh my gosh. But it's a
style and it's awesome.
And everybody kind of knew a
little bit about Mario's voice.
- [Chris] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Right I mean Mario's voice is,
it's a guy named Charles
Martinet does the voice
from the comics it obviously,
or from the comics,
from the video game.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it's obviously, it's super iconic.
You don't hear him say a whole lot.
- Yeah.
- And really, uh the video game itself
doesn't truly explore so
much the character of Mario.
It's really, the character
of Mario is kind of
whoever is playing the game you know.
The Mario, or Luigi, or
Peach, or Bowser, or Toad.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Or any of these characters, Wario,
these characters are
all just kind of avatars
for the player.
And so, when they wrote the script
and they reached out to me about doing it,
it was really kind of like
how are we going to
flesh out this character.
And who is this guy?
Like, what world does he live in?
How can we tell a 90 minute long story
about the character that everybody knows.
- Yeah.
- But they don't really know his story
other than he's on a mission
to go save a princess.
So fleshing out the voice was part of that
and finding you know the best voice
that would suit a 90
minute long narrative.
- 'Cause these are iconic characters.
- [Chris] Sure.
- Like for an entire
generation, like mine.
And then even my kids,
my six and eight year
old love playing Mario.
- Yeah it's so exciting to
think that people like us,
who have kids, who we
grew up playing this game,
but those kids also play the game,
it's like a multi-generational experience.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That we're all gonna have
our own bits of nostalgia
of our childhood and there's
a ton of that in the movie.
Like so many Easter eggs for people.
- Oh yeah.
- Who grew up playing Nintendo games.
- Were you excited to play Bowser?
- Uh yeah, I was totes excited because,
(laughter)
In a way Bowser is the
secret spice of the movie,
- [Kelly] Misunderstood.
- He's the devil arrr incarnation monster,
you know, he's like the
Darth Vader of this universe.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Jack] And that's a
lot of fun to play, yeah.
- I just love the fact that like,
someone has to call you and
be like so there's a villain
and we thought you would be perfect.
- Yeah.
- Like, what is that like,
receiving that information,
that like we think you
would nail villain. Like.
- Well you know what, I,
I took it more as like you're'
the bad boy of this movie.
- Okay I like it. That filter.
- You know you're the, it get
- Yeah.
- It's like metal, the
hardest rocking character.
And mischievous, I could
connect to it right away.
- I love,
(laughter)
I love you so much.
- You're so, so good.
- It's so good.
- You nailed it, you nailed it.
- You guys.
- He is so good in this movie.
(applause)
You're clapping now, you're
gonna be clapping twice as hard
when you see the movie, it's so good.
- [Chris] You're gonna
be clapping your pants.
- And how you do the
voice, this bellowy voice,
I can't even describe
the voice that he does
and it's so, it's so outstanding.
- I know but casting is
so important and it's so,
it's interesting how,
literally y'all are all A
level at what you do like,
and I've done animation
but like it's a difficult
thing to like come in
and play different characters
and like who it's gonna be.
Like that's a, it's a really, it's not,
I don't think is as easy
as people might think
and they did such a great job
like everybody is so stellar
and you have your own.
Like how did you come up with Toad's?
- Really it was something,
I was working with my partner on the voice
and she was saying I think,
she had thought of somebody in our life
and she was like what
if you did it like Doug?
Do it like Doug.
And so I was trying to get all
of the rhythms and the syntax
like this guy, like a dear friend of ours.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Then I got with the
director, we were adding that
and he kept on going, a little bit higher,
and I was like how how
how bout how bout here.
Maybe higher. Okay maybe,
maybe like here, like in here.
How bout a little bit higher.
Okay a little bit higher than there.
He goes, can you go a
little bit higher Keegan?
I can try. And and.
(laughter)
And then eventually I got to a place
where I literally thought to myself
can I just act like, as an
actor, just act like I'm going
(air sucking in)
on a helium balloon.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then starting the session
(in high pitched voice).
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then starting the
session and doing the voice.
(cheers and applause)
- It just takes,
it takes a very bold
person to just walk in.
I remember the first time I ever did it,
I was like you want me
to what? And I was like.
And I just got nervous about it
'cause it's like there's so many people
in the studio watching you.
- And you're going for it.
- Look like a tool.
- Yeah, you're like you're
going for it, by yourself.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Keegan] It's so rare
to be able to do it
- [Kelly] On an island.
- With other people you know.
- [Kelly] Anyway, you all do a killer job,
I'm so excited about it.